trading trump for desantis as president  if you said to me  either trump or desantis will be  president who do you want it to be  i think trump's less dangerous  because although he's dumber he gets  less done he's so unorganized and he's  so caught up in nonsense that i think he  gets less done  um  so  it's  if rogan can disabuse trumpists of  following trump and supporting trump  great and if he can do it in a way that  feels like that beta trump no i'm alpha  i'm with rogan whatever whatever it  takes right to to disabuse them of those  beliefs  but if it leads to desantis being the  next president or the nominee then we've  got some real problems and i don't know  the answer i don't know where it's going